can we just take down the tude to really
know I'm you haven't even seen the
beginning its attitude I apologize there
was a poor choice of words I just mean I
need you to show me the respect that you
would show your boss because he's your
house right oh you you did the black
boys thing we had it's not a black voice
in actuality not a black voice no you do
a black voice you don't remember when
you was in that meeting he was like we
gonna get it laid up for here this
meeting lit it was very lit you did it
at the staff meeting when you were like
I keep him 100 when if I never kept it
100 when you added that AP Calculus to
my class agree to disagree
listen I hate to break up this pleasure
party of delusion but I have work to do
Wow
so if you'll excuse me I'm gonna do my
thing that's some live voice so teach
what are the test results Teddy you my
friend are dyslexic you also have this
calcula that's what I got we're not done
you also have a processing disorder I
got a touch of prostate cancer she
didn't touch my ass one time boy welcome
to night school
we need to cram four years of high
school into a semester I think his mama
breastfed him being there is the future
the conventional way this isn't gonna
get it done
Bobby in ring with the square root of 81
what
this woman is a brick wall you either
pass the midterm or you out of my class
we're gonna have to test you want to
explain to me how you got a perfect
score I know I didn't get a perfect
score because I missed a few on purpose
snitches are [ __ ] what I'm going to
work come and get your chicken from the
Lord
petty hey suit you got on is dermis hey
I'm where I'm supposed to be at a fast
food point next to a strip club must
stay in the right spot
I can smell cocoa butter and fried
chicken at the same time you can get on
my baby
[Music]
ready to get started I'm not playing
with you with the capital Belgian
waffles you starting to force my hand
water is comprised of rain you got it
right Eddie where's that smell
now that for gas you best answer my face
it's in my mouth you got my lips up how
you feeling today Teddy I'm feeling fine
waffles
[Music]
night school is about Teddy Walker who
is a high school dropout I'm done with
this he says that's it I'm gonna be
successful on my own but y'all end up in
stupid student debt you look like bad
credit already he's gotten by by being
somewhat of a con artist a mouth that
can pretty much talk his way out of any
and everything you go take my car my
baby in the back she knows baby in there
Wayne Wayne ends up being a barbecue
salesman a very good one not a lot of
woman to take this much deal but I know
you can when an unfortunate incident
happens at work he finds himself in a
position where he needs that GED what
brings you back to PD I'm glad you asked
right now I'm an amazing job in sales
but I'm here now taking my GED you would
have to go to night school
yo ring my house no I don't hear color
he thinks he's gonna be able to do the
things that he's been doing hustling
fast-talking and charming um
teacher but his teacher happens to be
Tiffany Haddish you're the night school
teacher no I'm just the [ __ ] that like
to wear blouses yes I'm the night school
teacher overworked underpaid but her
reward is seeing people succeed in here
I am the best teacher in me Oh world the
character we felt like scream Tiffany's
this dance is for students only get out
my way [ __ ] when you have two very very
talented comedians like Kevin Hart
Tiffany had it so the energy problem
there's no cure for what you have oh my
god
I got learning herpes there's no such
thing as learning herpes they are both
competing forces of nature that's what's
so fun about this movie night school is
the movie about second chances what's
the square root of 81 I don't know my
suspicions were right and you my friend
are dyslexic that's what I got I'm not
now did you say it makes sense you also
have a processing disorder I got a touch
of prostate cancer she didn't touch my
ass one time I see a processing disorder
my process you are just one big
beautiful mixed drink of learning
disabilities okay
so how do we fix it let's talk solution
well there's no cure for what you have
oh my god I got learning herpes there is
no such thing as learning herpes I'm
gonna think Teddy Walker what brings you
back to Piedmont I'm glad you asked
right now I'm an amazing job of sales
but I'm here now it's it in my gb you
would have to go to night school you're
in my house are you doing the black boys
no I don't hear color
you're the night school teacher no I'm
just the [ __ ] they like to wear blouses
yes I'm a night school teacher let's do
some introductions hey yo what up I'm
Bobby
you can Skype into the class yeah if
you're doing time at the Georgia
Correctional Facility your next name's
Jalen how about you ma'am I dropped out
of high school so I wanted to get my GED
before does he have to live in Randy's
parents laundry room my name is Luis I'm
going to become a singer-songwriter oh
no not like Julio Iglesias oh it's gonna
be a long semester that's what's up
she's not like the teachers that we had
back in the day this woman is a brick
wall
school policy if you don't pass that
test you're out what's the test really
why do you wear black laundry day
so you wore yellow it's fresh it's clean
you tell her my face what's it look like
I'm doing you gonna take my car my baby
in the back she knows baby in there
Wayne Wayne petty suit you got a lot
it's dumb as hey I'm where I'm supposed
to be at a fast food playing next to a
strip club uh stay in the right spot I
smell cocoa butter and fried chicken at
the same time I need you to go out there
and I need you to stop no no I can't
flirt and my day was innocent now it's
all about the bots are dag I ain't gonna
crack that book like a walnut why did
you start there wouldn't you want to
start in the front to stop
this dance is for students only get out
my way [ __ ]
please continue with the Pythagorean
theorem
the issue is you're clinically dumb I
know it there's no cure for what you
have
oh my god there's no such thing as
learning herpes ah you must Muslim wait
I'm sorry what what's going ok
why were you in ring with the square
root of 81 what what's the square root
of 81 I don't know hey Jerri hey that's
real cool what you did for me in a
blackboard you know that's what I was
talking about when I just said watching
out for each other you know you scratch
my back I'll scratch yours oh there's
not gonna be any more back scratching
Teddy that's the last time that happens
and what was really going on with you at
the board anyways nothing nothing no I
was just I wasn't prepared if you're not
gonna do the work drop the class why
would you know Carey hey I'm gonna do
the work you'll see we'll see
yes we will great superb excellent good
this is the grill for you I called it
the Obama come on say Emma's my Elmo the
Pip Boy
I call this the big black machine
oh my god do you smell gas a little bit
came out but how's the nervous that's
just a quick you're the best salesman
I've ever seen I can see you being a
stockbroker like me could you give me a
job I wish I could my boss won't let me
hire I thought that the Mark Zuckerberg
he dropped out of Harvard you dropped
out or Piedmont high that was a couple
credits shy of graduating I got to get
my GED I'm the principal of this school
I can do whatever I want yo ran my house
are you using a black voice no I don't
hear color all right let's do some
introductions my name is Carrie I'm here
to make a little extra cash so that I
can afford this one that I got but
that's none of our business
welcome to night school this book is
kind of thick I thought it'd be more
like a leaflet if you're not gonna do
the work drop the class no I'm gonna do
the work you'll see we'll see
yes we will great superb excellent good
[Music]
you're gonna be a financial analyst I am
and it starts immediately I've been
waiting on the Lord to bring me a
pint-sized little man who can fill this
out let me get you chicken from the Lord
you take that test all right tenderize
your way thank you
the pimps are you trying to get your GED
are you trying to get your GED yes you
can get out my way [ __ ]
my suspicions were correct oh you're
clinically down there is no cure for
what you have oh my god I got learning
herpes I got the give the keyboard given
boy you did the black waist thing we
have it's not a black voice not a black
voice you don't remember when you was in
that meeting he was like we gonna get it
lit up in here this meeting lid it was
very lit I'll keep it 100 when have I
ever not kept it 100
[Music]